bonjour a tous fini les chaînes et la
traite négrière c'était il ya 170 ans
jour pour jour
aujourd'hui la france abolissait enfin
l' esclavage dans ces colonies un moment
d'histoire que l'on peut difficilement
oublier et un pan de l'histoire auquel
vous vous rendez hommage ici à la maison
de la négritude à champagney notamment
parce qu'il concernait aussi ou en tout
cas parce qu'il a impliqué les habitants
de l'époque
evelyne vous allez nous raconter pardon
je me trompe de prénoms martin
vous allez nous raconter pourquoi les
habitants de champagne étaient concernés
par cet événement alors c'est vrai qu'au
départ on veut se pose la question
pourquoi parce qu'il n'ya pas d'esclaves
à champagnier mais les habitants de
champagne et ont été sensibles à la
question de l'esclavagé 1789 ils
rédigent leurs cahiers de doléances à la
demande du roi louis saez et au milieu
de toutes leurs difficultés ils vont
évoquer l'esclavagé des noirs tout
simplement parce que le jour là le
notable du village qui est gardes du
corps auprès du roi est en permission à
champagné et va les sensibiliser à
l'histoire de l'esclavagé des noirs
alors ce que vous nous racontez là
c'était en 1789 un contexte qu'on
connaît aussi en période de révolution
l'abolition de l'esclavagé arriver bien
plus tard 1848 qu'est ce qui s'est passé
entre temps un champagne a du coup alors
à champagné entre-temps brawn a continué
parce que c'était des villageois très
modestes qui ont continué à souffrir
mais qui sait qu'ils étaient vraiment
unis il y avait 1 va dire un point fort
à champagné c'était leur religion ils
étaient fiers d'être chrétien et c'est
ça qui donnait cette unité ce musée
était moins aujourd'hui de cette
histoire la maison de la négritude on
parle aussi des droits de l'homme ça va
beaucoup plus loin que simplement
l'abolition des esclavages tout à fait
alors c'est vrai que dans cette salle
c'est un endroit qui est on va dire très
touchant c'est la cale qui va
représenter ce voyage donc les
difficultés et ensuite c'est vrai qu'on
ne peut pas ne pas aborder l'histoire
aujourd'hui puisque si l'esclavagé a été
aboli
on le retrouve sous d'autres formes et
on à 250 millions d'esclaves dans le
monde alors dans le cadre de cette
journée d'hommage aujourd'hui toutes les
visites sont gratuites dans votre musée
nous allons d'ailleurs vous proposer
d'écouter ces réactions de visiteurs ce
matin voilà donc parmi les visiteurs ce
matin effectivement cette maman et ses
deux filles
pourquoi vous avez voulu venir
aujourd'hui avec avec vos filles visiter
ce musée vous madame
parce que j'avais visité le musée il ya
une dizaine d'années et puis il était
important pour moi comment on revient
régulièrement dans la région qu'à un
moment donné elles puissent aussi avoir
connaissance de du musée et puis ce qui
s'est fait plus en détail hormis ce
qu'on sait déjà
donc voilà c'est la raison c'est la
raison de notre visite aujourd'hui vous
leur aviez déjà parlé d' esclavage vous
bah c'est un sujet qu'on peut aborder
comme un autre donc puis c'est vrai que
c'est un sujet intéressant qui nous
parle aussi ou tout du moins important
donc voilà oui d'une certaine manière a
directement on en a déjà discuté oui
alors vous les filles vous venez de
visiter l'exposition ça fait quelques
minutes que vous avez fini de faire le
tour qu'est ce que vous avez retenu de
cette visite
bah on n'a retenu que il y avait encore
des gens qui étaient esclaves et qu' il
y en a qui souffrent encore l'esclavagé
c'était quoi exactement qu'est ce qu'on
qu'est ce qu'on vous explique ici
comment vous vous l'avez compris bas que
s'est passé c'était surtout des gens
qu'ils étaient maltraités qu'ils aient
un travail très dur et que c'était
horrible en fait avant ça vous touche
d'avoir compris ce pan de l'histoire
d'avoir compris justement la façon dont
on traitait ses hommes
bah oui parce que il souffrait et il y
en a qui mouraient de famine et c'est
triste et c'est toujours pas fini
c'est toujours pas fini c'est à dire bah
y en a encore qui ce mec ce club qui
souffre encore donc des enfants oui
alors ça c'est le volet sur sur l'
esclavage moderne c'est quelque chose
qui vous a touché ici aussi dans le
musée bah oui pour te voir par exemple
que des enfants comme nous pas obligés
de travailler alors que nous on est à
l'école
il va défendre plein de l'école mais il
travaillait et pas du couvent voilà
merci merci à vous trois pour ce
témoignage merci on retrouve tout de
suite maintenant elle la mère de
champagne est la mère de champagney
marie-claire faivre qui est à mes côtés
vous êtes maire ici mais vous êtes
également présidente de la route des
abolitions parce que le public est
invité à aller plus loin pas uniquement
ici dans la maison de la négritude mais
avoir d'autres sites 1 de la région
concernée par cette abolition tout à
fait alors on invite des gens qui
souhaiteront faire la route des
abolitions esclavage a visité la maison
ce cher à fessenheim la maison de l'abbé
grégoire à ambert mesnil soeur anne
marie javouhey à challenges et puis la
maison de la négritude un champagne et
puisqu'on est dans les locaux
aujourd'hui je pense que ceux de cette
visite ça vous ne ressortirez pas
indemne
il faut vous dire aussi qu'ils encore un
énorme travail à faire sur la question
d' esclavage puisque comme il était
indiqué tout à l'heure de par le monde
entier on dénombre encore quelques 250
millions d'esclaves c'est vous dire que
la charge est ardue et que la mission
n'est pas terminée
malheureusement on ressent donc beaucoup
de militantisme qu'est ce qui fait que
ici dans cette région dans cette partie
de l'hexagone on est aussi impliquée par
parle esclavage par ces commémorations
alors je pense que de par nos racines de
champagne euro note notamment mais de
gens de l'est également
les invasions qui ont eu lieu sur le
territoire et ensuite le dur labeur des
paysans du secteur teintées aussi
exactement de la mine des mineurs ont
aussi travaillé sur le secteur ont fait
que les gens puisé dans ses racines à la
valeur du travail et de la solidarité
merci marie claire febvre vous l'avez
compris auront donc hommage à toutes les
victimes de l'esclavagé aujourd'hui
plusieurs commémorations sont d'ailleurs
prévues aujourd'hui